aislamiento que ha venido con la
pandemia durante los últimos meses no
solamente nos ha afectado física y
económicamente también ha generado en
nosotros sentimientos de tristeza de
preocupación sentimientos que en gran
cantidad de personas ha generado estrés
e incluso depresión ahora bien y las
familias que comparten el aislamiento
con niños antes de la pandemia de los
niños pueden asistir a la escuela al
parque con total normalidad ahora a los
padres abuelos y tíos les ha tocado que
reinventarse y buscar mil maneras para
distraerlos y jugar con ellos claro es
importante resaltar que la mayoría de
los casos contamos con herramientas como
get es libros aparatos electrónicos que
facilitan esta tarea
estas experiencias que le propiciamos a
los niños antes y durante la pandemia
los estimulantes diversas maneras y son
de vital importancia para su desarrollo
porque el niño no se con aproximadamente
100 mil millones de neuronas las cuales
se encuentran en un estado de inmadurez
y es a lo largo de los primeros meses y
años de vida que se genera la mayor
cantidad de conexiones neuronales
después viene un proceso conocido como
pueden neural el cual es la eliminación
de las neuronas que no sea
potencializaron estas conexiones
neuronales se generan por medio del
proceso de aprendizaje el que se da a
través de las experiencias y estímulos
que tenemos en nuestro entorno
experiencias que ustedes han propiciado
en los niños por ejemplo un niño que ha
podido asistir al zoológico oa una
granja y ha podido ver animales como
leones y vacas le será más fácil
asociarlo con una imagen representativa
recordar su alimentación
su sonido onomatopéyico a un niño que
solamente los ha podido ver en cuentos
un niño que constantemente ha asistido a
reuniones familiares a centros
comerciales tendrá habilidades sociales
más desarrolladas que un niño que ha
pasado su vida con un reducido número de
personas
aquí hay algo importante para añadir y
es que en esta etapa del desarrollo se
encuentra los periodos críticos y
sensibles del aprendizaje los que se
conoce como un espacio en el que el
cerebro se encuentra más predispuesto a
recibir cierto tipo de estimulación esta
estimulación le permite adquirir de
manera óptima habilidades tanto
cognitivas como conductuales es
importante resaltar que si ésta tiene
estimulación no es adecuada estas
habilidades se podrían ver alteradas e
incluso disminuidas
ahora pensemos cómo sería eso posible si
estamos en un estado constante de
privación de la libertad donde no
contamos con el apoyo familiar y de
profesionales y no tenemos las
herramientas necesarias para suplir las
necesidades de los niños bueno está la
situación a la que se enfrentan los
niños que viven con sus madres en los
centros penitenciarios creen que ellos
centran el mismo nivel de estimulación
que un niño que vive en un hogar regular
veamos en colombia cuando una mujer va a
ingresar a un penal y se encuentra en
estado de embarazo con tiene un niño
pequeño debido a la ley 17 79 del 2014
el artículo 88 le permite el niño estar
con su madre hasta la edad de 3 años
momento en el que el cual pasa a un
familiar que se puede hacer responsable
de la crianza del niño oa una
institución encargada de buscarle una
familia un hogar sustituto
lo importante de resaltar en este tipo
de situaciones es que no se garantiza la
calidad de vida del menor los gastos de
crianza ni el desarrollo integral
en el censo realizado por el inpec en
septiembre de este año se nos enseña que
en un total de 50 madres gestantes 11
lactantes y 38 niños menores de 3 años a
nivel nacional
ya sea que estemos hablando de prisiones
aquí en colombia o en el extranjero es
inevitable pensar que los niños se van a
encontrar en ambientes hostiles donde la
mayoría de los casos se pueden enfrentar
el hacinamiento a la desvinculación
familiar ambientes no adecuados a
situaciones de violencia de lenguaje
inapropiado y a falta de acceso óptimo a
la salud
por otra parte las madres que se
encuentran en estado de reclusión
tienden a padecer de ansiedad depresión
y en muchos casos dependencia a algún
tipo de droga o al alcohol lo que afecta
directamente su relación materna en
otras palabras que también afecta el
desarrollo óptimo del infante
sería fácil pensar bueno si no es un
ambiente adecuado fácil que los niños no
vivan con sus madres pero aquí
intervienen dos cuestiones claves la
primera es que por ley el niño puede
estar con su madre aunque sea los
primeros años de su vida la segunda es
que en esta etapa del desarrollo se
crear algo conocido como vínculo de
apego el cual básicamente es un recién
nacido debe de crear al menos una
relación importante con un cuidador
principal para que su desarrollo social
y emocional se con total normalidad esto
también le va a generar confianza al
niño para poder ir a explorar su entorno
lo que como vimos anteriormente es muy
importante para su proceso de
aprendizaje
como la licenciada en educación
preescolar realicé un máster en
psicopedagogía la cual es la disciplina
encargada de estudiar a las personas y
su comportamiento en situaciones de
enseñanza y aprendizaje durante mis
estudios de máster asistí a un
monográfico titulado psicopedagogía
prisión e inclusión el cual con él en
conjunto con mi experiencia docente me
inspiraron a crear el proyecto tejiendo
la paz trayendo la infancia a través del
estímulo el cual es un diseño del
programa de estimulación temprana
dirigido a las madres de los centros
penitenciarios tomando como referencia
el centro penitenciario para mujeres de
barcelona- barras durante la detección
de necesidades puede ver muy de cerca la
situación de los niños en particular los
cuales sus respectivas madres no se
llevaban bien dentro del penal por lo
cual no les permitían estar juntos para
jugar como consecuencia de eso cuando se
encontraban en el jardín
se busca en todo el tiempo pero sin
interacciones siempre terminaban en
agresiones debido a que no habían podido
aprender a convivir el uno con el otro
paralelamente uno de los niños estaba
pasando por una serie de cambios
rutinarios con su madre lo que
manifestaba a través de conductas
agresivas juegos solitarios poco apetito
no descansaba bien a la hora de la
siesta y el poder observar cómo esta
situación afecta de manera tan directa
el desarrollo de un niño
me pusieron a pensar en que el alcance
de este proyecto debe ir orientado en
dos direcciones la primera es la
intervención con los niños de
estimulación temprana para poder crear
un equilibrio con la falta de estímulos
que tienen en su entorno lo que le
permitirá crear y dejar crear
habilidades de manera óptima dentro del
penal la segunda es el trabajo con las
madres por medio de la orientación
psicopedagógica dirigida a la educación
emocional para afianzar su concepto de
que tiene de sí misma su confianza y sus
lazos afectivos pero porque considera a
las madres como punto clave para el
proyecto bueno quien te hace el rol de
cuidador no ha creído que si hemos
tenido no sé información extra o alguna
ayuda las cosas hubieran podido ser
mejor con nuestros niños quizás ahora
podrían ser diferentes
bueno eso es normal porque no tenemos un
manual de cómo actuar con un niño es en
cada caso específico por eso considera
las madres como un punto fundamental en
el proyecto porque son el primer
contacto que tiene el menor con el mundo
y son ellas que le dan su apoyo
emocional y su cuidado
ahora pensemos si es difícil para
nosotros que nos encontramos en nuestro
hogar que contamos con muchas
herramientas el poder hacer el
seguimiento a nuestros niños cómo será
si estuviéramos en un estado de
reclusión donde no contamos con los
recursos necesarios para desarrollar
nuestro rol como cuidador
es por eso que al principio de la
intervención se planteó una sesión
dirigida a las madres donde se va a
trabajar la autonomía emocional esto con
el fin de reforzar su autoconcepto y que
ellas se sientan mucho más empoderadas
para desarrollar sus rol como madres
después se les pasará a capacitar en
conceptos básicos de estimulación
infantil y desarrollo infantil y por
último se le darán unas estrategias de
estimulación para que sean ellas quienes
puedan desarrollar esas actividades con
los niños no solamente potenciando las
capacidades de los niños sino afianzando
ese vínculo entre madre e hijo
para la presentación de estas
actividades se creó una cartilla en la
que encontrarán 70 estrategias de
estimulación que les permitirán
desarrollar las habilidades de
movimiento coordinación lenguaje y
socialización en niños de 0 a 3 años
al poner en práctica este proyecto se
pretende velar
por las necesidades que puedan tener las
poblaciones menos favorecidas
también porque este tipo de situaciones
que no esperamos que son impredecibles
nos generan miedo pero cuando podemos
transformar ese miedo y ese temor en
voluntad podemos descubrir grandes
habilidades en nosotros habilidades que
nos ayudarán a formar a favorecer a las
personas en situaciones de
vulnerabilidad e incluso a las personas
que necesitan segundas oportunidades